it's time for the dish are you hungry
it's a story that might make you wanna
oh go hunt for a bite Italian food
famous around the world and if you ask
any Italian who's the best cook well
they're going to tell you their mother
yes Ian Lee takes us to London where one
Italian family has made a successful
business at a mama's home cooking
I'm not gonna ask you I'm just gonna
give you the frittata to try okay yes
there's a good chance you're not eating
enough at least that's what the mamas
that love me and Mama will tell you oh
and they'll let you know you have to eat
Manja you're gonna hear that last word a
lot
I learned this word this is a very much
means eat in Italian it's part of our
culture it's part of our tradition it's
a part of our life
Italians without food it's a
I'm not sure they are Italians actually
I'm used to Great Foods coming from
Sicily for Italian Pepe corsaro while
living in London nothing could match his
mom's good old home cooking and one of
my friends
just joking but why don't you bring your
mama over to cook
and there was my your Eureka moment
correct exactly
that Eureka moment turned into La Mia
Mama a restaurant run by Italian moms
but for that idea to work Pepe first had
to call back home so you call your mom
and what does she say I'm not joking she
was like okay listen I found this ticket
I can come there we're gonna do the menu
and we're gonna develop it
and that's how we all began
not only did Pepe's mom known as Mama
Anna come over but his sister Mama Sarah
also joined we're doing the fresh Cavite
pasta this is a Sicilian pasta very easy
very easy so you take a little piece of
dough like this right you put it in the
pot it just press a little bit and roll
down
show me all right
press a little bit and roll you see it's
a great job you've done like an amazing
job come on
this Cavatelli pasta is being served
with a pork cheek and pistachio pesto
pesto is
a little bit of flavor
salt pepper and sunflower oil
the dish may look simple but it's Simply
Delicious
they're so good your face was talking
already
oh
but oh I didn't give you the pork
chicken so you have to try with it I'm
sorry but you have to try one more
now it's completed it's like the whole
recipe like this cooking good food was
easy but they needed to fatten up the
operation how did you find The Mamas we
put like a um a post on social media
we're recruiting like mamas we don't
want professional chef you want home
cooking it's what I want original home
cook those home Cooks first auditioned
over the phone it's okay come over you
do like um a demonstration you cook
something for us and then we start from
there many mamas stay in an apartment
together as they become paid
professional chefs most of the mamas
they were all Housewives or they were
doing a completely different job in
Italy so they're quite intimidating but
give them two three days and they loved
it
at La Mia Mama food is more than just
something you eat
how do you want people to feel when they
eat your food first of all we want them
to feel happy but then falling in love
with that food
it's a romantic experience almost
Italian we are romantic yes
was it working with your mother oh my
God
now okay no stay without there perfect
Dream came true actually it's amazing
it's a beautiful Dream It's A Beautiful
dream yes
can you imagine your life without lamia
Mama now no absolutely no no she said it
in English now no absolutely
turned into a beautiful dream for Pepe
too because he finally got that good
home cooking of his Sicilian childhood
we're always going to be children
forever mama you know we're going to be
babies you know you can be 40 50 you're
always going to be Mama's Day you know
Pepe now has three restaurants serving
that home cooking hello because let's
face it no one Cooks quite like Mom
for CBS mornings Ian Lee London
that was great that was fantastic I love
the apartment I want a reality TV show
about the apartment where all the Mamas
are living there's non-professional
chefs now cooking for everyone I think
it's one of the most loving things you
can do is to prepare a meal and to give
it to someone that you care about I
think that's so sweet it's one of those
stories that you we wish we could smell
because just looking at it you can smell
the garlic that's on the list I'm going
there for sure nice I like it that was
great